banning pegasus a european watchdog says
it's time to make the spyware illegal
governments have been accused of using
it to violate the privacy of activists
and journalists and who can stop pegasus
and why now this is inside story
hello and welcome to the show i'm sami
zaydan well the balance between privacy
and security once again back in the
spotlight in europe this time it's data
protection watchdog is sounding the
alarm about the threat posed by
surveillance software specifically the
israeli pegasus spyware it allows
governments to access people's personal
information and decrypt private
communications the warning comes as part
of the eu's efforts to ensure european
institutions respect the right to
privacy when they process personal data
and develop new policies
the european data protection supervisor
says pegasus could lead to an
unprecedented level of intrusiveness
able to interfere with the most intimate
aspects of our daily lives
a ban on the development and deployment
of spyware with the capability of
pegasus in the eu
would be the most effective option to
protect our fundamental rights and
freedoms the official goes on to say at
the center of debate on tools like
pegasus should not only be the use of
the technology but the importance we
attribute to the right to privacy
pegasus is one of the most powerful
spywares out there it's been developed
marketed and licensed to governments
around the world by the israeli company
nso group
it's known for its zero click attack
capabilities that means it can exploit
vulnerabilities and break into a phone
without the owner doing anything like
clicking on a malicious link
once it breaches a device the software
can allow a hacker to record phone calls
copy messages and even secretly record
video
amnesty international has accused
countries including morocco the uae
saudi arabia and mexico
of using the spyware for political
surveillance
[Music]
let's bring in our guests into the show
we have joining us from geneva stefan
dugan chief executive officer of the
cyber peace institute
in brussels fannie heedwiggy european
policy director at access now an ngo
defending civil rights and privacy
online and in new delhi siddharth
varadarajan founding editor of the
digital news portal the wire his phone
was hacked using pegasus spyware a
welcome warm a warm welcome i should say
to all of you if i could start with
fanny so pegasus has been around since
2011 hasn't it why is there only talk of
banning it now
one thing is for sure is that as the
european data protection supervisor puts
it the question is whether spirituals
like pegasus should have any place in a
democratic society and the answer is no
it has and if it has no place in a
democracy then it has no place anywhere
in the world
and while it's uh already a bit lit but
we would like to see in this ban
following the defenses
it's coming after 11 years isn't it
well these reforms uh always take a long
time and what the reports recently have
shown is that and the capabilities that
you presented it's not an exaggeration
to say that the use of such spyware
fully eliminates the right to privacy
not only the targeted person but also to
a large extent all of their contacts so
since the infringement is so severe it
affects the essence of the right to
privacy and it can never be
proportionate there are no legal
safeguards that can mitigate the harms
and the only appropriate solution is an
immediate stop on the sale and transfer
and development of such tools
okay stefan i'm wondering if
part of the concern is the fear
of heavy commercialization of software
like this that government spy agencies
may not have a monopoly for very long if
this is left unchecked
it's a very good question and we built
upon what has been just said before
it's a question of proportionality and
escalation this cannot be any
proportional use of this kind of tools
when there's proliferation of these
tools and they are proliferating because
of the market its supply and demand so
in a very strange situation where
private sector is dictating who can spy
on who who can purchase the capacity to
be in
an opportunity to transform your phone
into a portable spy that is going to
listen to what you're saying this is
going to transmit what you're looking at
and everything about your your personal
life so the fact that
there's a market that goes way beyond
nso way beyond pegasus there's a lot of
organization that are specialized in
this software and its offensive cyber
capabilities is key to the problem it's
a quick scent we are building something
on quicksand
talking about how it impacts personal
life siddhart you were a victim of
pegasus
as well as the fact that of course you
are a journalist you're a key member of
civil society how did it impact you and
your job
well uh when i found out um
last year that my phone had uh had been
infected
um
obviously your mind
uh does all kinds of uh analysis as to
you know
who have you been in touch with
what sensitive sources might have been
compromised so on and so forth and
essentially when a journalist is
targeted
in the way that i was and other
colleagues in india i think a total of
you know we found 40
40 plus journalists in the list of
numbers
from the leaked database as part of the
pegasus project and we were able to
confirm infections and
i think at least five or six journalist
phones
the attack is actually
on much more than the privacy of the
individual
the attack is on
press freedom
the attack is on democracy
the attack is uh on our ability to
you know hold governments to account
by the work that we do
did you ever find out who
targeted you
the matter is under investigation in
india right now because a number of
victims approach the supreme court and
the supreme court has set up a committee
to investigate and actually get to the
bottom of this my reasonable surmise
based on the fact that nso says it sells
only to governments
is that the government concerned is the
government of india
so one of its agencies because
my number is part of a database of
targets
in whom
no foreign government could conceivably
have an interest
the only government that would have an
interest in that range of characters
opposition politicians
you know uh
human rights defenders lawyers
journalists etc
uh would be the government of india so
that's a reasonable summarize and we
know from
the new york times is reporting
that uh a contract was signed in 2017
between uh
nso and the government of india
all right of course that is the
suspicion of course we we can't say that
that is the case for sure just to be
fair to the union government however i
think fanny wants to get in come in on
that fanny
yes that in addition to the reports and
attribution based on those uh
facts and and suspicion there are eu
governments that have already admitted
uh that they have bought and used the
pagozu software
one of these governments is hungary or
poland within the european union despite
all the all the um exposure by
journalists and activities done in the
past um they have practically no shame
of admitting the use and abuse of such
technology against opposition
figures journalists lawyers and
potentially human rights defenders so we
we hope that based on these facts and
again not just reports
but but actual uh admitting of these
governments the european union
institutions and member state
authorities will follow up with the
investigations
um such as the hungarian civil liberties
union which is a lead human rights ngo
in hungary
launched
different
legal avenues and they are pushing for
instance the european commission to
start an infringement proceeding against
hungary following following the
reporting and
do you think that the eu will actually
ban it what's your feeling if you look
into your crystal ball
i
so
i believe that from a legal standpoint
there's no other choice right than to
ban but banning is a very
it's a word that needs to be put in
legal practice you know it's not uh it's
not a simple act of banning not easy to
actually put it into practice absolutely
we'll come back on that but i i think i
saw for a second there stefan was
angling to get him go ahead stefan
yeah it's weird what uh just mentioning
the the eu is in this very interesting
situation where eu member states are
buying this software
and the same time eu member states are
victims of attack in the sense that
people on the international realms are
targeted if not officials of of eu of eu
states so it's interesting to see that
the existing legal framework because
there's a legal framework that looks
into our proportionality transparency
the fact that there's a dual use
export rules that are in place in eu but
all of that did not lead to a situation
when there's control there's a clear
lack of control so indeed
trying to enforce control bits by bits
won't
work this is the demonstration what we
need to have here is a ban is a
moratorium a global moratorium on the
usage development and deployment of the
stores
even if that's the case siddhart
it seems like so far from the cases we
know it's mostly governments and
intelligence agencies which have been
using the israeli software pegasus
would they really care about a ban i
mean some of these agencies are set up
to work secretly and spy and violate
laws of of other at least other
countries and other nationals would it
really make a difference if it's banned
for for the agencies which are currently
using it as far as we know
look it depends on on which countries
and what what's the manner of the ban
uh i think the the route that the united
states has chosen to follow
which is to sanction the company
involved nso by putting it on the
entities list
uh
might well create a situation where nso
is then unable to offer a services to
any government if it if if the u.s
action is taken to its logical
conclusion
of course there are a number of
governments that
have chosen to
um you know
that are not concerned about the
previous implications i should add sammy
that
uh while i'm as ready as you are to cut
the government of india's slack
in terms of saying well we haven't
proved that they are the ones who've
used it the fact is that the government
of india was given an opportunity in
parliament and in the supreme court to
deny
that they bought and used pegasus
against us and they chose not to do that
as well right so so there is a
presumption based on denial and and i
would say that you know based on the
absence of denial so i would say that
you know essentially this is a tool this
is you know i think one of the other
panelists used the phrase dual use
the the you know this is uh very
powerful technology that obviously has
an application
as far as espionage or counter-terrorism
etc is concerned but uh it's literally
very well designed to be used for
uh you know targeting civilian and you
know political opponents of government
and i think this is where the danger
lies that this is you know going well
beyond
the individual privacy implications
we're talking about governments
undermining democracy right in india we
have evidence that
opposition politicians were targeted
with pegasus in the midst of an election
you have to think what does this do to
the fairness of an election
uh in in poland in in even in israel uh
the kind of evidence that's emerging
suggests that pegasus is extremely
damaging
or spyware like pegasus to the very you
know essence of democratic institutions
which is why i think a moratorium or a
ban
uh no matter how it is designed and
implemented is absolutely essential it's
absolutely essential is it easy fanny to
actually
put a ban into practice though how much
oversight is there over what some of
these governments and intelligence
agencies do especially if you start
talking about secret service programs
who knows right i mean edward snowden
revealed a lot of things that surprised
many people
i i was going to say that one one
investigatory tool at the moment is at
the hands of the european parliament
who just as after the snowden
revelations they are doing this inquiry
committee
but um while i share your skepticism
about how national security agencies
will follow
fundamental rights recommendations
around data protection and privacy
especially in the european union but
hopefully even more broadly there are
legal rules around national security and
just because they claim that the use of
this technology is on national security
grounds it doesn't mean that there are
no more was applicable
and
and this is the let's say hope that we
can put this in practice and there's a
need to strengthen the democratic
oversight over surveillance measures
and specific legislations
around european law should be
enforced in a much better way
national data protection authorities in
some countries have the right to
investigate which is the case in hungary
as well but for um unfortunate maybe
political reasons the the um authority
concluded a very formal investigation
and didn't get into the specifics
whether the concrete use against those
people were lawful or not
interesting stefan
is there something that we need to
address in terms of the relationship
between big tech corporations and
governments and how much of a difference
would a ban make to that kind of
relationship that's developing
your question
how feasible is a ban and how to
implement it
at least technically a ban would be very
helpful in the sense that it will
disrupt
the supply and the demand all of this is
about supply and demand you have
government entities that are asking for
these tools and then on the other end
you have just an ecosystem that is
exploding in numbers of companies that
are providing these tool sets which
means that public money today taxpayer
money goes to
fuel investments in these companies that
are doing what they're investing into
making the internet not secure for
everyone so a band would at least you
know disrupt this uh
demand increasing that is creating an
increase of supply and also let's be
very very clear but let me jump in
stefan and ask we've heard reports of
some middle eastern government simply
hiring people who've worked for
top-notch
western corporations and intelligence
agencies
is there any i mean can you really ban
the software the knowledge of the
software it's easily copied and
developed by other governments who don't
have a lot of care or respect for human
rights and privacy
no that's that's exactly this but if you
if you start with a ban if you start
with the moratorium you're going to
disrupt the demand you disrupt the
demands you disrupt the supply which
means there's going to be less people
that are going to specialize themselves
into the insecurity of the internet
so that's that's a very good first step
in order to give a kind of a hit for
this market that is just going unchecked
something i would like to say
this is discovered because of the work
that we civil society are doing and here
i would like to commend the work of
access now i mean funny is there and the
citizen lab and amnesty tech and
others that for years you're saying 2011
i mean investigated with our own mean
these activities i would like to see the
same investment of public money in
public procurement of these tools going
to civil society which are investigating
this abuse to human rights
siddharth how would a ban impact the
court cases going on
against nso group maybe you could also
talk a little bit about your personal
experience and the sort of legal action
you're pursuing
well you know there's various sorts of
legal action that's uh happening right
now nso itself is subjected to uh is
facing
court cases in america uh thanks to
uh whatsapp and apple uh and i think
microsoft has joined that as well uh and
then there is there are cases that have
been filed in france by
by some of the victims of pegasus and me
and some colleagues in india are also
party to that
and then there is the mata in india
which is not strictly a legal proceeding
as in terms of a case against the nso
but is right now at the cut
currently at the stage of a fact-finding
probe
by the supreme court of india which is
trying to ascertain from the government
of india whether it bought pegasus and
used it and if so on whose legal
authority
and uh i think depending on what emerges
from that
uh
probe uh we will see a whole can of
worms uh in both in legal and political
terms opening up in india so this is
just the beginning for you siddharth
absolutely i think that you know for us
the
uh the matter in india really is a
question of pinning responsibility on
the government
uh so what happens to nso in that sense
is secondary but i think nso's own
challenge is going to be quite
considerable
in the california court where facebook
and apple have tried to hold into
account
finally i'm wondering why has pegasus
attracted so much attention how is it
different from other spy tools
i
i believe that
it's very tangible for everyone how the
con the complete access to your phone
that pegasus has which is actually a
little bit even more than what you as a
user would have as control over your
phone it can even record secretly
conversations that you would not be
aware of so i think i think that harm is
very tangible everybody understands how
there's no limit between our life in the
offline and the online world and that's
how there shouldn't be a limit between
how we enjoy our rights both offline and
online
and uh the specific cases that were
revealed all around the world show that
um these spyware tools and pegasus in
particular are used to target political
opposition human rights defenders and
journalists so not targets that you
could even claim legitimate national
security purposes it's a it's a clear
abuse of such tool but as i said
we would argue that legally even that
there's a very very limited if at all
cases where you could use these tools
but these cases show how how they were
abused and while i fully agree that
there should be a control around the
sale and and we discussed export
controls
but the real another real but the
additional shame i think in the past few
months within the european union has
been that we are advocating for these
norms externally while we cannot even
enforce them within the borders of the
eu and that's why all eu institutions
and the european commission as well must
uh really um be a bit stronger with the
with the member states to ensure that
that the charter is in fact uh enforced
indeed from a technical perspective
stefan
pegasus is not the only spy software out
there or spy program we've known for
years
if not for decades of programs like
echelon
sig int to edward snowden that there's
plenty of tools and ways for governments
to spy on people right
now there is it's a longer history of
intrusion and spying it's a long history
of
proliferation of offensive cyber
capabilities
but what
what made the pegasus story
its way to the headlines
is the scale and is the capacity for a
private entity to dictate across the
world who gets the capacity to spy on
who
and and this is absolutely going against
any proportionality because
it's uh
it's exploiting vulnerabilities
on everyone's infrastructure the
internet that you and i are
using
uh you have people that are just looking
into the holes in the codes they are
stockpiling this and they are waiting
just to deploy for the one that can that
can purchase it so that's really the
game changer here and
it is indeed siddharth how much of a
challenge to democracy
is this israeli spyware program
and when you think about what we've
known so far who's been targeted
sometimes opposition figures sometimes
human rights activists lawyers
journalists like yourselves
that's basically the nuts and bolts of
democracy isn't it
absolutely and this is why pegasus is so
dangerous right i mean if
nobody is denying that you know if you
go go way back in history
governments have you know you so
government to government espionage right
you mentioned echelon for example uh you
know government to government espionage
is a well-known phenomenon right there's
a legal you know it's not governed by
any legal code or international law
quite frankly uh uh but you know for
example the planting of a listening
device in an embassy that one government
would do uh during the cold war even now
i presume all that happens
pegasus is that plus so much more
and
you know what has emerged about the way
pegasus has been used is that this
military this capability that until now
we had assumed
was being used only for the purposes of
one state trying to get one up on
another
this has now entered
the phones of
politicians journalists human rights
defenders lawyers in india we actually
found one case of a young woman who had
accused
the chief justice of india of sexual
harassment
uh we found that eight telephone numbers
linked to her
had been targeted with pegasus were on
the database suggesting that they were
targeted with pegasus and so you imagine
how
in the hands of unscrupulous uh you know
law enforcement in the in the hands of
unscrupulous governments in the hands of
unscrupulous intelligence agencies how
this can be turned into a weapon to
silence the voiceless and the weak to
target uh the you know political
opposition
to uh to steal a march on
uh on and suppress free media so you get
you know you basically [ __ ] uh the
ability of journalists to do their jobs
uh this is a recipe for dictatorship
quite frankly uh so you can you can you
can you can go through the motions of
having elections and having courts and
having free and you know having a free
press but if uh the ruling party acting
through its agencies is able to deploy
pegasus uh and uh you know uh uh con you
know get to get a bird's eye view of
what the opposition and what journalists
are doing at all times then you have
undermined the essence of democracy and
this is the real thing
it is indeed i'm afraid we are out of
time so when i have to thank our guests
stephane dugan fanny heedwiggy and
siddharth
and thank you two for watching you can
see the show again anytime by visiting
our website aljazeera.com for further
discussion head over to our facebook
page that's facebook.com forward slash
inside story
you can also join the conversation on
twitter our handle there is at aj inside
story from me sami zaydan and the entire
team here for now it's goodbye
you